- You've said that this album
is your most honest album
so why do you think so?
- Because I started so young,
there's a huge part of me
that didn't get a chance
to develop my identity
in a normal setting,
so when I was working with Disney,
it was the best time of my
life and I had a great time.
I have nothing but good things to say,
but it was a bit more controlled.
There were certain things
that I was, you know,
had to do and not maybe go into,
like figuring out what my sound would be.
So, I've constantly been trying to make
my music better and better.
Because, I know that people may not think
I'm the greatest singer,
but I just work my ass off and
I love, I really love writing
and creating and creating
melodies and growing
and I felt like this was my
chance to say all the things
that I wanted to say in that way,
which was talking about relationships
and talking about difficult times
or being vulnerable or
being stuck in your head,
'cause, you know, I can do that a lot,
but I wanted it to feel good.
I wanted it to feel
like every word mattered
and you could feel it physically.
I'm still in the studio actually now
because I feel like it's inspired me
and I just wanna keep going.
- It's a creative time, yeah.
Isn't that funny?
You make an, that always
happens to me too.
I make and album and then
after I'm releasing it
right while I'm doing it,
I'm doing another one.
- Exactly.
- It always happens like that.
- I'm like, I don't I don't, just
- But I wanna point something out
because doing "The Voice" especially
has been really interesting
because a lot of people always think,
'cause you said, Oh I
know people may not say
I'm the best singer.
The best singer in the world,
talking to everyone in
the world right now,
is not the loudest and is not the,
oh my god you have to
sing like Whitney Houston
every time you do it.
The best singers in the world move you.
And that comes from all
different sounds and styles,
so from a singer to a singer,
it's beautiful what you do
and I love your record
and I love big huge songs,
but I love singing your music.
It means something and it moves people,
so don't ever negate your
gift, 'cause it's powerful.
(audience cheers)
That's what what I wanna say.